we're crossing to the ukrainian foreign
minister who is speaking at the moment
dimitro caleb we're also working
to make sure that the cryptocurrency
will not become a safe haven for russian
money
the
ability of russia to sell gold has also
been blocked we're also blocking the
attempts to bring money into third
countries and to rebuild their business
our position is simple
if we are going to block the
sources of russian economy then you have
to do it
fully that's the only way to
stop the
aggression by creating internal pressure
on president putin who are not stopping
at the
sanctions already imposed
while uh russia ukrainian children die
under ukraine under russian bombs
sanctions are not enough
i must tell you that in my talks with
our partners i hear often
such an argument that let us that we
have already imposed unprecedented
sanctions we will continue to impose
them we've never
had such a sanction experience and we
have to make a pause and see how the
sanctions already imposed the work and i
say directly to this and uh this morning
uh i also said to one of the european uh
foreign minister
unsealed the war as long as they were
last
and russia kills our citizens the
sanctions must continue
to be imposed new sanctions
and we have a
specific list of sanctions which we want
to be imposed
and
we are going
through this list item by item we're now
at the threshold of
the
introduction of the fourth round of eu
sanctions it will be
sanctions against legal uh uh entities
and russian companies especially in the
defense industry russian defense
industry i don't have to explain
anything there
we will
exert maximum pressure to uh
to sabotage the to stop the russian war
machine the eu the the united states
have already uh rejected uh russian oil
we are working hard to make sure that
the european countries will do the same
uh germany is still a challenge because
it's quite a difficult decision for them
but even
we're working with them too and we
believe that
they will hear us eventually and they
will
approve the decisions which will uh
help
balance
the situation in
germany and will help
stop russian gas and oil into europe uh
the russian
uh oil gas and and coal uh are drenched
in ukrainian
blood we keep selling this uh to our
partners and to the
european uh mass media every dollar is
paid to the
russian war machine which is uh killing
ukrainians and
undermining european security i want to
use this opportunity to express
a specific demand and a call to
western companies stop buying
russian
oil gas and call we also insist
that world ports be
close to russian ships
that they should refuse to
handle
russian cargos
the the cargos that are addressed to the
russian federation to disconnect
other russian banks from swift in
particular the russian zber bank
the
international companies are refusing to
work with russia and mass we work
with uh
managers of those companies we
try to explain the threats uh
with them what their work on the russian
markets uh entails i also want to thank
to all the ukrainian communities and
activists abroad who at their own uh
initiative who who pre pressurize those
companies while why it's not
good to work in russia from all points
of view we are grateful to you
for your initiative and efforts don't
stop the international
business should leave russia both for
moral and pragmatical reasons first work
in russia is a reputation
causes reputational damage nobody wants
to be associated with a war criminal
second
the russian economy is closing uh a
catastrophe a crash the
russian uh economic
is more and more unpredictable companies
uh try to
escape to uh
they have to rescue their capital from
the rebels of russian economy the
russian government already threatens
nationalization
international capital must
account might
understand these
risks and minimize them
three weeks of war
and you can see that putin has already
ruined
russia's reputation as a business
partner and
business
climate
209 companies have fully left the
russian market and stopped cooperation
with russian partners
more than 200 limited their work we know
those companies were not content with
their
position we
see their tricks to try to stay on the
russian markets and we will continue
to exert pressure on them the list i've
just uh presented it's a list of the
most
famous companies the world giants
who are uh systematic for the russian
markets and they are leaving the markets
and they create a huge
gaps
holes on the russian markets which will
affect russian consumers there's also a
list of companies who didn't uh
leave russia this is ashan metro and
others
pirelli and
hotels are quarter intercontinental
hotels as for machine building
honeywell
mohawk industries arconic cosmetics
oriflame
kimberly clark
salvatore ferragamo phil
morris
saint paul
once again i urge them to leave the
russian markets as soon as possible
they remain
the the consumers should buy quote those
companies until they stop working in
russia russia must be stopped now
using all available
resources and uh and and while the
russians
the russia and while the ukrainians are
stopping
russians so paying with blood and and
ruined cities the least
those companies can do is leave the
russian market and
help us thus to stop the machine of
russian aggression
the results of the
russian
economic
crash
led to
a change the
relative parity between grievner and
rubel uh in russia the average wage is
now 350 dollar
when
in future it will be 270 dollars and now
the average wage is about 500 dollars a
month and and
is not
falling radically
in in the future in the near future
the ukrainians will live better this is
the result better than the russians it's
the results of putin's aggression
against russia
every day of this war makes russians
poorer we're also working with
international partners over a large
scale
financial support for the ukrainian
economy and business the ukrainian prime
minister and president the whole
government every day
uh are
rebuilding the economy in such a way to
create the most comfortable conditions
for ukrainian citizens and ukrainian
enterprises
our uh businessmen and enterprises are
having a hard time now
the government is doing all they can to
uh
create uh soft conditions uh for
for the ukrainian business thank you
this is uh
everything those were three days of
intense work without sleeping uh with uh
uh
high emotions today
when i had another international
telephone call
one of my colleagues the minister of
uh foreign affairs of one of uh european
companies said friend
you've shouted at us
you've shamed us you've urged us and
over the past three weeks and it was
important for us to mobilize
and to approve the necessary decisions
those were three difficult weeks not
very diplomatic but uh this is war and
this is war diplomacy but the main thing
is that we have uh results which i have
just described to you and the second
point is that we are not stopping or we
are moving forward and we will
complete this
matter and we will win and for the whole
world who
wants to live in peace and security